hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to ghost supermarket now
this game was recommended to me by some
of you guys I don't know who exactly
because when I loaded this up it didn't
seem like it was gonna be all that great
it was one of uh one of those games you
know it looks like one of those games
and that it doesn't look very good on
the surface but all the people that were
talking about the game said that it was
incredibly scary and I've played these
games before where they don't look like
much and they actually turn out to be
scary so we're gonna find that out right
now so our objective is we need to find
Keita defuse a bomb that's for some
reason in a supermarket and then we need
to escape all while trying to get away
from ghosts and apparently the bomb
timers at 6 minutes and 24 seconds so I
don't know what to expect from all of
this
all I know is that this is a weirdly big
supermarket where am I supposed to be
can I run oh oh hey I found the bomb but
I know I have to find I have Oh her kita
is a person keith is a lady with a hold
key to be well I found the bomb so
that's a good first step and I don't
know why this is called ghost
supermarket when there obviously aren't
any ghosts hello I think that's rain
hello hello hi
is there anybody by the name of Keita
I'm all alone and vulnerable in a
supermarket totally susceptible to any
ghostly intrusion into my body I don't
know what's with all random lag spikes
probably a testament ow that is it is it
hi how's it going there hi Oh at least
we don't have to collect notes
oh are you kita oh oh oh is that what it
meant
hey is that what it meant by oh that's
so cool okay well it's not so cool but
that's kind of cool or anyway I didn't
know that it was gonna be like guiding
OH
God okay ketta it's always the one you
don't cut the red wire
what oh come on
but that's always the one you know what
you don't cut the red wire with the blue
I don't know what about what do you
suppose that even mean that's stupid
it's stupid cuz I don't want to rip
another game in half with my razor sharp
criticism and it is not that sharp and
not that good oh the lag spike whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey how's it goin there
how you doing well go whoa Jesus that's
kind of uh it's kind of spooky a little
spooky there so there's good ghosts oh
hey how's it going there so there's good
ghosts in them this bad goose this place
is scary is this gonna be one of those
procedural oh hey well that's a big-ass
Keith
goddamn okay uh okay all right well
suddenly everything decided to go
batshit insane maybe this is one of
those procedural games where it seems
misleadingly odd in the beginning and
then it just kind of evolves into
something bigger I have no idea I mean
it was highly rated by me despite all
the lag spikes in the initial
apprehension I have towards playing this
game why it hasn't redeemed itself in my
eyes just yet okay I think the bomb was
over here no it's not is this randomly
generated or something
well I supposed to not be able to find
this side of a [ __ ] oh no it's it's
randomly generated it just must be the
location of the bomb and the items are
randomly generated hello dose dig use
once again I am complete whoa whoa whoa
that is a big scary face alrighty then
so I've only got five minutes left on
this bomb timer and I don't we here we
go alright kita be a little less obscure
or the yellow one if there is a yellow
one but there's not a yellow one I
forgot to buy mock thanks ask the book
of bombs not me just google it yellow
well this doesn't help look at those
prices oh come on it's always the one
you don't cut well that's stupid blue
wire
ah come on this is so dumb why do i need
to do this you are a little creepy I
will give you that if it wasn't for the
random lag spikes
I might actually appreciate this game
Oh
in case you didn't notice you were
eating and you were tasty okay I'm gonna
give this over to give this one more try
I'm gonna give this one more good try
and we're gonna see where it goes from
here cuz whoo oh hey how's it goin there
buddy but oh but in ski let's see if I
can find something there was the big
black ghost thousand oh the book of
bombs just cut the red I didn't know
that there was an actual book of bombs
well that's so stupid
okay there's the bomb cuz oh god stop
that I have the book of bombs I have the
book of bombs get away from me Oh God
pigment hey buddy how's it going I just
need to find kita and key kita and key
Acura Nicki the cure is in animu
oh man the lag spikes hello I'm open and
vulnerable to your thrusting capacity he
goes to use I don't know why I said
those words but I'm just feeling random
nonsense out of my bowl hole
anybody an ebow there's a key okay I got
it all god damnit a one screw off
Oh God Wow I found the hallway of ghosts
apparently oh [ __ ] me god damn it
it's so stupid that's so stupid
okay since I couldn't get the ending of
the game here's the ending right now oh
this is going to be oh oh it's got me
the ghost
oh oh I'm in a supermarket at night oh
my mom sent me to get milk but I'm
feeling warmer frequent customer Elgar
oh okay Oh help me oh I found a key oh
oh
the store will be closing in 10 minutes
oh goodness
Kyra I'm sorry Oh mom to defuse little
man oh yeah we're in it oh my god oh oh
it's here red wire or blue wire Kyra
which one it's probably the red wire
don't trust me got it oh I can't get out
here oh let's go don't worry more like
probably Gilliam is he [ __ ] gone now
Oh what the [ __ ] did I say